aucun drone ne peut éteindre l'aube de
Noël
nous verrons saluer même sous terre dans
un abri Antibes
nous remplirons nos cœurs de chaleur et
de lumière ici et nous ne ressentirons
jamais ni le manque de courage ni la
peur d'être vaincu un message de près de
10 minutes que la tradition veut
apolitique mais le roi évoque tout de
même en images les difficultés
économiques et sociales que traverse le
pays
dans ces temps de grande anxiété et de
difficultés l'essence de notre
communauté s'exprime que ce soit pour
ceux dans le monde qui font face à des
conflits des familles ou des
catastrophes naturelles ou ceux ici qui
cherchent le moyen de payer leurs
factures et de garder leur famille
nourries au chaud pour l'histoire c'est
l'un des maîtres du 17e un artiste
immense qui sur ses toiles religieuses
représentait le peuple de la rue
mendiant ou prostitué pourquoi les
pauvres te
je voudrais graver leur image ici je
suis contente qu'il ait parlé de ça car
t'en demande galère en ce moment il se
rend compte de ce qu'on vit ça nous
apporte de l'espoir
ces messages de Noël télévisés sont en
rendez-vous incontournable des fêtes
pour les Britanniques un rituel
kelisabeth II a inauguré en 1957
tradition immuable année après année
depuis 65 ans
le youtubeur au 5 millions d'abonnés
surtout des jeunes fait le bilan d'une
année compliqués sur le plan personnel
habitant à proximité d'un collège il a
été reconnu et depuis sa vie a changé
gros la journée c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
en plus du harcèlement mastu as aussi
reçu une menace de mort il vit désormais
les volets fermés pour avoir un minimum
d'intimité sur les coups de midi un
homme est entré dans un centre
communautaire kurde et a ouvert le feu
deux hommes et une femme sont décédés
d'autres personnes ont été blessées chez
un coiffeur l'homme a aussi tiré à
plusieurs reprises devant ce centre
culturel kurde en décembre 2021 ce
conducteur de train retraité avait
attaqué un camp de migrants au sabre
deux d'entre eux avaient été blessés
comment expliquer son geste présumé son
père en est aujourd'hui incapable oui
non pour ça il était vraiment renfermé
il vivait pas comme tout le monde
là on n'est pas du tout dans le même cas
de figure c'est à dire que cette
personne qui effectivement
s'autoproclame raciste n'a pas été
épuisé dans un livre ou dans une
doctrine ou je dirais dans une idéologie
plus globalement ce type d'acte c'est il
s'autoproclame c'est lui sa propre
idéologie si vous voulez la gauche elle
accuse l'état d'avoir négligé le danger
de l'extrême droite nous croyons
absolument pas au hasard quand il s'agit
d'assassinat de militants et de
dirigeants kurdes à Paris il y a
maintenant 15 jours
que les autorités avaient été alertées
bon monsieur monsieur Alliot on est
limité désormais par le temps de parole
comme vous le savez ce qui est
d'ailleurs pose beaucoup de problèmes là
aussi à la Libération en France il se
trouve que je peux pas vous donner plus
d'antenne pour cette raison là que je
viens de le faire j'avais le droit à 5
minutes pour échanger avec vous
juste consistant à bouger vers le haut
la partie du corps située de chaque côté
du cou ah oui
les épaules ce qui peut signifier
l'ignorance ouais l'impuissance il y a
quand même un faisceau médical ou en
tout cas d'information médicale qui
tente à accroître que cette personne
n'est pas complètement normale mais ce
n'est pas ce qui n'est pas le cas d'un
certain nombre
de terroristes anciennement qu'on a
qualifié déséquilibré qu'il n'était pas
pour le coup est-ce que tu veux que je
me taise
c'est toi qui vois
c'est toi
placer en unité psychiatrique samedi
soir l'homme se décrit lui-même comme
une personne raciste dépressive et suite
idère des traits de caractère également
décrits par son entourage lors de son
audition il confie être en proie à une
des étrangers devenus complètement
pathologiques suite à un cambriolage en
2016 et là personne ne me trouve rien à
la Ligue des droits de l'homme qui vous
attaque et pour le voile donc faut et
vous avez parfaitement raison de
souligner que ceux qui vous attaquent
ils ont d'autres ambitions parfois que
ils avancent parfois masqués la Ligue
des Droits de wolble je le rappelle et
pour le fou voilà les défend le voile
l'auteur présumait des faits c'était
initialement rendu à Saint-Denis pour
tuer des étranges et il se serait ravisé
faute de cible quant à l'arme il se
lassurait procurer il y a quatre ans
auprès d'un membre du club de tir auquel
il appartenait
c'est la meilleure sensation que je n'ai
jamais eu
au Canada on ne peut pas tirer avec des
automatique
donc quand les enfants ont vu ça ils
m'ont dit papa il faut qu'on y aille on
verra bien j'ai pas plus révisé un tout
petit peu mais on serait peu de temps
beaucoup de chansons ou pas d'ailleurs
oui c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]